eating healthy is something which
dietitians and nutritionists across the
country encourage people to do but an
obsession with eating healthy foods is
now a growing problem this is known as
orthorexia but it's an issue that's not
officially recognized in a clinical
setting it's almost a little bit
worrying that orthorexia is still not
seen as classified as an actual eating
disorder because I see the catastrophic
impact it can have on clients every
single day in my clinic and I'm also
contacted frequently across social media
with people that feel like they're
really struggling and not being listened
to and thanks to the promotion of clean
eating and wellness on sites such as
Instagram orthorexia is now more common
than ever
Instagram is dangerous when it comes to
food so dangerous nutritionist like
Rhiannon are worried it will take a
death before changes are made for
somebody that is suffering from any type
of mental health illness especially
orthorexia with the variety of
influences claiming that what they eat
can heal something or solve something
that isn't necessarily correct and true
and it can cause a condition to get even
worse rather than becoming a picture of
health
many people are restricting their diet
so much that they become unhealthy and
starved resulting in serious illness so
you've got this kind of vacant stares
like very pale skinny arms
pixie Turner developed noorthoek SIA she
was influenced into eating healthy
through Instagram but then herself
became an influencer she now uses her
story to help others falling victim to
this illness I recognize that I did
something that was really harmful I've
been very honest and very public about
it for a number of years now for that
reason but I have so much anger still at
these people who with no qualifications
and no expertise whatsoever put me in
this position what I was then harming
myself but also others and that anger I
now try and use and the most productive
way possible and that's I think why I do
what I do but there'll be people out
there who have been influenced who will
be angry with the people like you
yes and they are that is totally valid
and I accept that fully in a statement
Instagram told Sky News we do not allow
content on Instagram that promotes
eating disorders and we remove any
content that does this is something we
really care about so we work with
outside experts to make sure our
policies are working and to help us
improve it's over 20 years since
orthorexia was recognized by scientists
and as more people share their
experience of what they call clean
eating there are now fears that there
are more and more people developing this
physical and mental illness in some
rasheed Sky News